Rock said that you are the change you've
been waiting for what are you going to
do differently now that he's president
well I'm going to try to be more active
in the community try to volunteer more
be write my congressman write my
senators why wouldn't you have done that
if the pain well McCain doesn't inspire
the confidence i think that brock obama
inspires well i think now especially in
the victory of the selection i think
people seem so much more united people
are willing to stand up with their voice
and actually say i'm not satisfied with
what's going on you know I want
something to be different I think if
he's gonna listen that's ideal
good question I'm gonna keep doing I'm
already in service i'm gonna keep doing
that you're gonna keep doing what
service are you working a non-profit too
if we've been doing that regardless of
who was elected president yeah
definitely I'm gonna be able to watch
our president I couldn't before I would
turn it I would find netflix i would do
anything to not watch him i will look at
our leader you know what it ain't gonna
be easy and there's some bad decisions
that are probably gonna happen along the
way it's a great question pay attention
to politics and you wouldn't have done
that if mccain about I'm not sure that's
the case Oh community service as he
suggested yeah would you not have done
that if McCain had been elected well no
probably but he didn't really push it as
much yeah he's not pushing that
instruction also I've been he's been
talking about the global-warming a lot
too and I've been using a lot less
electricity and stuff yeah there's more
McCain was elected I don't think I would
have thought about it they make people
more aware like being greener like like
maybe like my next car will be a hybrid
or something that uses less gas so Jeff
what an SUV
no not about an SUV but now I just feel
like I should like buy a hybrid I don't
know probably picturing morals public
service you wouldn't have done that if
McCain a better life no um you guys you
don't know necessarily what's going on
coming out is helps you learn about it
and I think what you have done that even
if we can have been president no be more
opinionated talk to my congressman take
a more active role in being political I
think what he wants would you have been
doing that if McCain of an elective yeah